die wohnungssituation ist den großen
teilen der bundesrepublik immer noch so
unbefriedigend dass tatsächlich
außerordentliche maßnahmen erforderlich
sind um hier schneller abhilfe zu
schaffen durch die überhöhten mieten
fehlt es hinten und vorne an geld die
parade wo ich noch auf die weltmächte
ich bitte einfach
bezahlbarer wohnraum ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr mal wieder
in dieser kontext folge wollen wir uns
anschauen wie sich die deutsche
wohnungspolitik verändert hat welche
maßnahmen ergriffen wurden und warum
wohnen trotzdem immer wieder zum problem
wird vom massiven staatlichen
wohnungsbau nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
hin zur forderung nach enteignung großer
wohnbau konzerne heute warum gelingt es
der politik nicht dauerhaft für
ausreichend bezahlbaren wohnraum zu
sorgen willkommen bei context ich bin
theo koll
[Musik]
in vielen deutschen städten steigen die
mieten seit jahren in frankfurt lag der
quadratmeter 2018 bei 13 euro 59 in
münchen sogar bei 17 eur 73 in berlin
hat sich die angebotsmieten zwischen
2006 und 2008 zehn verdoppelt was aber
zur wahrheit auch dazu gehört im
vergleich mit anderen metropolen waren
die mieten in der hauptstadt über
jahrzehnte vergleichsweise sehr günstig
das ändert aber natürlich wenig am unmut
über den anstieg
immer wieder demonstrieren sie gegen
hohe mieten und die wohnungsnot in
berlin große konzerne wie deutsche
wohnen sollen enteignet werden fordern
einige auch darüber stimmen die berliner
bei den abgeordnetenhauswahlen in einem
volksentscheid ab das ergebnis
56,4 prozent stimmen für enteignung aber
enteignung als wohnungs politisches
instrument ist hochgradig umstritten
schließlich müsste das land die konzerne
mit milliarden entschädigen geld mit dem
man ansonsten neue wohnungen bauen
könnte damit wir enteignung verhindern
weil wir das nicht wollen müssen wir
jetzt mit einer klaren regelung zum
mietpreis oder bringt die grenze in den
städten wie berlin wo menschen aus ihren
vierteln vertrieben werden dafür sorgen
dass es zu dieser maßnahme nicht kommen
wird und das ist auch mein vorschlag
dass auf bundesebene den städten
ermöglicht wird wo wirklich die mieten
explodieren dass man dort mit
preisobergrenzen einziehen kann eine
enteignung diese jetzt wieder in die
debatte eingebracht wird führt nur dazu
dass der mangel anders verwaltet wird
aber nicht dass er aufgehoben wird diese
enteignungs kampagne ist ja ein hilferuf
ist ein hilferuf der mieter in berlin
welche möglichkeiten aber haben staat
und politik um auf dem wohnungsmarkt
erfolgreich einzugreifen im bereich
wohnen gibt es vier zentrale politische
stellschrauben die einen genaueren blick
lohnt sozialer wohnungsbau
eigentumsförderung
wohngeld und mietrecht springen wir kurz
zurück ans ende des zweiten weltkriegs
juli
berlin die ehemaligen reichshauptstadt
ist nur noch eine trümmerlandschaft
zu mehr als drei viertel zerstört sind
städte wie köln kassel koblenz mainz
frankfurt an der oder würzburg
fast drei millionen wohnungen sind
völlig zerstört
2,5 millionen schwer beschädigt in
dieser situation ist klar dass der staat
sich einmischen muss um wohnraum für
seine bürgerinnen und bürger zu schaffen
und das erste wohnungspolitische
instrument kommt ins spiel der soziale
wohnungsbau also staatlich geförderter
und bewusst preiswerter vermietete
wohnung
1950 wird in der bundesrepublik das
erste wohnungsbau gesetz verabschiedet
die grundlage für den sozialen
wohnungsbau der folgenden jahrzehnte
innerhalb von zehn jahren finanziert der
staat den bau von 3,3 millionen wohnung
doch das system kommt mit einer
schwachstelle in jeder minute entsteht
seit 1953 in der bundesrepublik eine
wohnung soweit diese wohnungen mit
steuermitteln gefördert wurden waren sie
vor allem für mieter mit bescheidenem
einkommen gedacht eine fahrt durch
manche sozialsiedlung lässt allerdings
daran zweifeln ob hier wirklich nur
kleine einkommensbezieher vorne zwar
müssen mieterinnen und mieter bei einzug
ihre bedürftigkeit nachweisen das aber
wird später nicht mehr kontrolliert die
folge im lauf der zeit kommt es zu immer
mehr viel bewegung mehr noch als die
fehlbelegungsabgabe
um das gemeinnützige wohnungsunternehmen
neue heimat in den 1980 er den ruf des
sozialen wohnungsbaus der spiegel hatte
aufgedeckt dass sich vorstandsmitglieder
der neuen heimat über tarnfirmen geld
abgezweigt hatte
der vorstand der neuen heimat wird in
urlaub geschickt der schuss der
journalistin des spiegels traf also ins
schwarze der vorwurf manager des
gewerkschaftseigenen unternehmens neue
heimat benutzen ihre posten um private
vermögen einzusammeln diesen vorwurf
trifft das ansehen der gesamten
gewerkschaftsbewegung der skandal bringt
die sogenannte wohnungs gemeinnützigkeit
von der auch die neue heimat profitiert
hatte massiv in verruf
1990 wird die wohnungs gemeinnützigkeit
im zuge einer steuerreform und energie
aus cdu csu und fdp abgeschafft man hat
damals anstatt das wohn gemeinnützigkeit
gesetz zu reformieren es gleich ganz
abgeschafft das war ein ganz klarer
fehler heute fällt uns das auf die füße
jetzt über zu wenige wohnungen haben
weil die besondere förderung in diesen
besonderen segment der gemeinnützigkeit
nicht mehr stattfindet unter der
regierung von kanzler kohl zieht sich
der staat zunehmend aus dem
wohnungsmarkt zurück begründet wird dies
damit dass der markt weitestgehend
ausgeglichen sei und tatsächlich
vermelden die nachrichten schon mitte
der 80er jahre sogar ein überangebot
köln stadtteil chorweiler in den 70er
jahren wurden hier 8000 wohneinheiten
gebaut ausschließlich sozialwohnungen
auch sozialwohnungen stehen leer 400
alleine in dieser trabantenstadt aus der
wohnungsnot der nachkriegsjahre ist ein
wohnungsübergabe es gibt mehr wohnungen
als haushalte hunderttausende von
wohnungen stehen leer vielerorts sinken
die mieten doch es dauert nicht lange
und schon wieder kommt es zu engpässen
steigende einkommen führen dazu dass
menschen in größere wohnung ziehen die
steigende zahl von einpersonenhaushalten
und der zuzug von aussiedlern aus der
sowjetunion erhöhen den druck auf den
wohnungsmarkt weiter hinzu kommt mit
blick auf den noch vorhandenen sozialen
wohnungsbau dass mehr wohnungen aus der
preisbindung fallen als neue hinzukommen
der bestand an sozialwohnungen hat sich
dadurch zwischen 2006 und 2009 10 fast
halbiert ist runter von 2,1 auf 1,1
millionen und damit sind wir beim
zweiten versagen deutscher wohnungs und
politik der eigentumsförderung in der
ideologisch aufgeladenen zeit des kalten
kriegs ist die förderung von
wohneigentum wieder in west noch in ost
ein selbstzweck wohnungsbauminister paul
lücke 1960 das familienheim ist
sozialpolitisch und staatspolitisch
wichtig gerade in unserer bedrohten
lager am eisernen vorhang hängt unsere
ganze zukunft davon ab persönliches
eigentum in möglichst vielen händen zu
schaffen die idee dahinter wer im
eigentum wohnt ist nicht so empfänglich
für sozialistische ideologie und zum
eigenheim bau oder kauf zu motivieren
werden steuerliche vorteile eigenheim
zulagen oder aktuell baukindergeld in
aussicht gestellt auch in der ddr
übrigens entstehen in den
siebzigerjahren eigenheim siedlung
eigenheim und noch dazu staatlich
gefördert im lande des volkseigentums
oder besser staatseigentums das scheint
ein widerspruch noch mehr wenn man sich
erinnert das miethaus besitzt durch
festgefrorene niedrige meet setzte dem
eigentümer mehr sorgen als einnahmen
bringt während der althaus bestand
überall in der ddr ob in staats oder
privatbesitz zusehends verfällt
entstehen am rande von provinzstädten
rund 10.000 hübsche eigenheime pro jahr
sie sind teil eines wohnungs und sozial
programms und vielleicht deswegen doch
kein widerspruch zum herrschenden system
aber in ost wie west gilt die quote der
menschen die in wohneigentum leben ist
so niedrig wie in keinem anderen eu land
über die hälfte der deutschen sind
mieterinnen und mieter und damit die
sich das wohnen leisten können gibt es
ein weiteres wohnungs politisches
instrument das wohngeld
wohngeld ist ein staatlicher zuschuss
zur miete
wer die entsprechenden voraussetzungen
erfüllt hat auf das wohngeld einen
rechtsanspruch
wohngeld ist kein almosen
die möglichkeit vom staat wohngeld zu
kassieren wird inzwischen von 1,4
millionen bürgern und familien genutzt
das sind sieben mal mehr als vor acht
jahren
1965 wird dieses wohngeld eingeführt
zwar wird in den folgenden jahrzehnten
mal über die höhe oder über seine
finanzierung gestritten und dennoch
bleibt es über parteigrenzen hinweg
unumstritten was aber wenn man in seiner
stadt trotz wohngeld gar keine
bezahlbare wohnung findet kommen wir zum
vierten und letzten instrument dem
mietrecht ein kurzes experiment auf
diesem gebiet wagte das land berlin ab
februar 2020 sollte der sogenannte
mieten deckel den anstieg der mieten in
der hauptstadt bremsen und teilweise
sogar rückgängig machen das ist der
größte tabubruch der jüngsten geschichte
insbesondere weil es am ende keine
rechtssicherheit gibt weder für die
mieterinnen und mieter noch für den
vermieter und eine landesregierung ist
stets eingehalten auch für ein
rechtsfrieden zu sorgen und den stellt
sie nicht her sondern sie sorgt für ein
absolutes chaos am wohnungsmarkt das
bundesverfassungsgericht aber hat wie
von vielen vorhergesagte den mieten
deckel gedeckelt das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat den mieten
deckel in berlin gestoppt das
entsprechende landesgesetz sei
verfassungswidrig denn der bund habe das
mietpreis recht bereits abschließend
geregelt heißt da der bund mit dem
mietpreis bremse bereits regelung zur
begrenzung der miethöhe getroffen hat
steht es dem land berlin gar nicht zu
die miete zu decken es war der
klassische fall von gut gemeint schlecht
gemacht im ergebnis führte den mieten
deckel zu weniger wohnungsangeboten und
zur zurückhaltung möglicher bauplanung
das absurde an der situation noch vor 15
jahren verkauften kommunen wichtige
wohnungsbestände um ihre knappen kassen
aufzufüllen also ein gold mit
gullydeckeln ähnliches denken wir
natürlich überhaupt nicht auch nicht an
die vergoldung des rathaus thomes aber
wir wollen natürlich unsere
schulsanierungsprogramm auch in
absehbarer zeit abschließen wir müssen
kindertagesstätten neu bauen dresden
wächst ja auch von den geburtenzahlen
her deutschland im wohnungs ausverkauf
wo immer öffentliche wohnungen verkauft
werden die meist ausländischen
investoren warten schon der soziale
wohnungsbau befindet sich seit jahren
auf dem rückzug die eigentumsförderung
hat nicht nennenswert dazu beigetragen
dass weniger menschen auf dem
wohnungsmarkt und wohnungen rangeln es
stellt sich also die frage was klar die
ampel parteien um die wohnungssituation
in deutschland zu verbessern
gehört doch dazu wenn man ein gutes
leben führen will dass man sich die
eigene wohnung leisten kann das auch
eine normale arbeitnehmern ein normaler
arbeitnehmer doch noch mal die
perspektive hat sich vielleicht ein
kleines häuschen ab zu sparen das muss
in diesem land möglich sein und dafür
müssen wir kämpfen und ich frag mich
echt auf wo die sozialdemokratie war als
man sie eigentlich brauchte weil das die
sozialen bindung aufgelöst worden ist
das ist ja nichts was man nicht ändern
könnte sondern damit wohnraum nicht aus
der sozialen bindung will kann man das
gesetz ändern an der stelle wir werden
das problem angespannter wohnungsmärkte
in deutschland nur dann lösen wenn wir
mehr investitionen in wohnraum haben
wenn mehr gebaut wird wenn auch wohnraum
aufgewertet wird hier die vier
wichtigsten punkte aus dem
koalitionsvertrag erstens die förderung
des wohnungsbaus
400.000 wohnungen sollen jedes jahr
entstehen 100.000 davon öffentlich
gefördert zweiter bauen soll weniger
kosten und das zu erreichen soll
serielles bauen digitalisierung
entbürokratisierung und standardisierung
gefördert werden drittens die
finanzielle unterstützung des bundes für
den sozialen wohnungsbau soll
fortgeführt und erhöht werden und
viertens außerdem soll eine neue wohn
gemeinnützigkeit mit steuerlicher
förderung und investitionszulagen
eingeführt wird letztlich ist die frage
nach bezahlbarem wohnraum aber nicht nur
eine frage der politik mehr menschen
wohnen allein jeder in seiner eigenen
wohnung am liebsten auch noch mit mehr
platz der anteil der
einpersonenhaushalte lag 1961 noch bei
20,6 prozent 2009 10 aber bereits bei
42,3 prozent
da hilft es auch nicht dass die zahl der
wohnungen pro tausend einwohner rinnen
und einwohner in den vergangenen jahren
gestiegen ist die politik hat immer
wieder massive steuerungs fehler gemacht
aber auch unsere ansprüche gestalten die
nachfrage auf dem markt auch wir müssen
uns fragen wie wollen wir künftig wohnen
auch darüber lohnt es sich zu
diskutieren reichen die pläne von spd
fdp und grünen um die probleme auf dem
wohnungsmarkt zu lösen was denken sie
schreiben sie es uns in die kommentare
für weitere nachrichten themen analysen
hintergründe und spannende recherchen
abonnieren sie unseren kanal wenn sie
nach dieser folge noch mehr kontext
sehen wollen dann schauen sie sich dort
das video mit meiner kollegin aminata
bailey zum thema legalisierung von
cannabis an und wenn sie mehr zum thema
wurden sehen wollen schauen sie sich
doch mal dieses video der kollegen auf
diesem kanal an